why
so Robert Reynolds the century was
created by Rick Veidt J Lee and Paul
Jenkins and first appeared in the
five-issue miniseries of Marvel Knights
the century volume 1 issue number one in
September of 2000 now for the most part
Paul Jenkins and J Lee are usually the
ones given credit for the creation of
the century with Rick Veidt having been
left out and there are a couple reasons
for this the first reason is because the
version of the century that we will see
in Marvel Comics is actually vastly
different than the version of the
century that was initially created by
Paul Jenkins and Ric Veidt then the
reason for this is because Ric Veidt
wanted a character who was going to be
introduced in such a way that it
appeared as though he was simply a
forgotten character that had been made
by Stan Lee but he wasn't going to be as
powerful as this injury was that Ric
Veidt one of the century to be more of a
toned-down character on the same level
as Iron Man but what we saw is that by
the time the comic had come to
publication that the century had been
given to us and a little bit different
of a way and was actually turned out to
be one of the most powerful characters
and the Marvel Universe the other reason
for why Rick Jones I'm sorry why Paul
Jenkins and J Lee are given so much
credit here is because they're
considered to be kind of the one-two
punch of the Marvel Knights series and
the reason why is because Marvel Knights
was simply just a series of
self-contained publications these were
instances where Marvel took existing
characters or existing teams and gave
them their own self-contained stories
that sort of existed outside of the main
events that you saw with earth-616 now
by 2006 Joe Quesada had had this sort of
revamp and had the Marvel Knight series
brought in to the mainstream Marvel
Universe but what we saw was that with
Inhumans volume number two that Paul
Paul Jenkins and J Lee had really kind
of established themselves as a very good
order artist and creator kind of team
and so what we saw was that the century
was considered to be their very first
creation and because of what we saw with
Inhumans volume two people were very
excited
see this century they were very excited
to see what would happen if Paul Jenkins
and J Lee had moved away from the realm
of using existing characters for marvel
Knight M Prince and instead had the
opportunity to create their own
character and indeed what we see with
this five-part limited series is quite
possibly one of the best stories to ever
come out of the Marvel Knights
storylines what we see as we begin with
issue number one is that Robert Reynolds
simply just wakes up one day realizing
that the century is him that he is the
century but that the void is returning
and the way this story is told to us
were given this sort of inner monologue
with Robert Reynolds where he talks to
himself while at the same time
interacting with his environment around
him and what we'll see here with issue
number one is that Marvel actually set a
set on the path of sort of having this
hoax going on sort of tricking people
into believing that the century was a
very old character what we see here is
that the century of course tells his
wife that there's no real reason for
concern that he simply needs to let the
dog out and over the course of the
remainder of this first issue we see the
century really kind of remembering who
he is really kind of coming to this
understanding now for the most part the
entire five issue series is going to be
Robert Reynolds regaining his memories
with his role as the century but this
sort of just begins the early steps of
him coming to an understanding of who he
is he begins to recollect on the fact
that it may have very well have been
years since he became or since he was
the century he doesn't know how he got
to this place in his life he doesn't
know how he got to this place where he
lived and lived has a house where he has
a dog and he has a wife he doesn't
really know any of this he simply just
realizes that he's here almost as if
he's waking up from a dream what we also
see is that he goes to a bookshelf and
takes down a book and for the most part
he begins to sort of reminisce on
himself he sort of begins to reminisce
on how it is that things got this way
how it is it he ended up where he's at
and again still trying to figure it out
what he also indicates to us is that
something called the void has returned
now we'll find out at the end of this
five issue series although there'll be
obvious clues to really tell us what's
going on but we'll find out at the end
exactly what the void is but we see that
one of the biggest can
turns that Robert Reynolds has is that
the void is coming back and that the
only hope that humanity has for being
able to defeat the void is Robert
Reynolds himself from here we see this
sort of jump back we begin to see the
sort of hoax that Marvel created what
they were trying to get us to to believe
that this century was a character who
existed in the 1960s and that somewhere
along the line the the artistry the
story the character had simply just been
lost and what we see is a sort of
backstory in the art style and the kind
of storytelling that we saw in the 1960s
where Robert Reynolds had stumbled
across the professor secret formula now
for the most part in this five issue
limited series we won't learn who the
professor is we will find out much later
on beyond this five issue limited series
that the professor was in fact dr.
Cornelius who of course played a major
role in the x-men schism storyline and
of course the web and X program that
gave Wolverine is adamantium but what we
see is that this Super Soldier Serum
seems to be some kind of serum that
maybe is on par with Captain America's
formula or maybe more advanced of course
as we'll learn later on that this the
serum is far more advanced than the one
that gave Captain America its powers but
we see this kind of transition back and
forth between these 1960s comics and the
depiction of the current events that are
going on with Robert Reynolds
remembering what's going on we see of
course that when he consumes the serum
that he takes on this sort of Captain
America kind of transformation where he
goes from being a relatively young
person to a large masculine blond man
kind of a depiction of what it meant to
be an athletic individual in the 1960s
we of course see that as Robert Reynolds
is remembering these events of him
gaining his abilities when he first
became the century that he uses his
powers to defend off a young woman in
order to really kind of establish
himself as a superhero of sorts we also
see that Robert Reynolds takes one of
the signature roles of superheroes in
the 1960s by developing his own suit and
again this was really kind of a hallmark
of characters in the 1960s and this is
one of the reasons why a lot of people
genuinely believed that the century was
actually a long-lost character
from the 1960s because in the 1960s when
you have the Jack Kirby Stanley era of
comic book characters one of the
hallmarks of their character their own
suits it's one of the things we saw in
spider-man the Fantastic Four the x-men
so on and so forth they really sort of
establish themselves as superheroes by
going through the the I guess a rite of
passage so to speak by developing their
own outfits now eventually what we see
here is Robert Reynolds taking a sip of
the serum and he really tells us that it
really kind of comes on as a rush that
all these feelings and all these
emotions and all these memories begin to
slowly trickle in and when they do he
remembers how great it was to be the
century he begins to remember what it
was like to to be such a superhero in
the eyes of humanity we of course see
that the current dog that's with him
when he was the century was his sidekick
called the watchdog but then we begin to
see that he kind of begins to question
himself and to ask was that real did any
of it really actually happen and this is
when we sort of begin to see this sort
of psychosis this kind of maybe
schizophrenic element of his character
that begins to come into play and again
Robert Reynolds begins to touch on the
void and then we actually see for the
most part what the void was capable of
and why it is that the void is
considered such a threat when we see
that the void is able to take on a full
contingent of the Avengers albeit the
Avengers from the 1960s and defeat them
single-handedly eventually of course
Robert Reynolds is able to defeat the
void and the void tells him that he will
return at some point along the line from
here of course we see that Robert
Reynolds begins to realize that with him
taking this serum that something's
happening that the void is going to
return and again he really takes this
time to kind of reflect on himself by
simply asking the question who are you
who is he as an individual is any of the
stuff that he recalls as the century
real from here we actually learn what it
is that he can do as the century now
this will be expanded on later on
especially when we get into our
discussion about the powers and the
abilities of this century but what we
learn here is that this serum moves the
centuries molecules an instant ahead of
the current timeline now for whatever
reason I'm not exactly sure why I think
its assembly just something again that
we just kind of have to
except from the Marvel Comics universe
but because of the fact that this
happens this century has the power of a
million exploding Suns and so basically
he can do anything there's nothing that
he can do his powers are absolutely
limitless and indeed and the current
publication albeit the fact that the
century has actually been dead for a
little while and been recreated that
we've never ever seen the upper limits
of the centuries power the closest we
ever got was during the world war hulk
store line which again is something that
we'll talk about later on in this video
but for the most part all this really
does is established to us what it is
that this century is capable of doing
and then in fact he is a wildly powerful
character from here we begin to see that
Robert Reynolds of course begins to
again go into this sort of psychosis he
begins to go in this into this sort of
mental I guess this place of mental
insanity where he begins to work on some
artifacts here and there some things
that remind him of who he was as the
century but due to his inability to
focus that he begins to consume more of
this the Super Soldier Serum and the
more he begins to consume this serum the
more he comes into contact with what
seems to be the void and in fact one of
the things that I would like for you to
pay attention here is how it is that he
treats this serum this super serum
really seems to be more like a drug the
super serum really seems to be more like
an addiction for him and what we see is
that as he begins to consume the serum
even more that eventually comes into
contact with the void and the void makes
its presence known in the form of his
dog which begins to talk to Robert
riddles and tells Robert Reynolds that
he would return and what this does is it
begins to ask us as the reader to ask
the question is Robert Reynolds simply
just crazy is all this in his mind is he
really just an insane human being or
does he really have powers we see of
course that as far as we can tell
perhaps in his mind perhaps what's
actually happening is that he's able to
combat the threat of the void in a
couple different ways the first is by
simply shooting an energy projection at
the void the other half is by trying to
convince himself and the void that
neither of them are real that neither of
them exists from here we see that he's
kind of in a broken-down position he's
really appears to be sobbing or at the
very
Li's trying to get a grip on his
situation which again indicates to us
that he may very well be insane but we
see that his wife arrives and for the
most part it appears as though he's
kicked the dog she also picks up the
glass bottle that apparently or
supposedly had housed the Super Soldier
Serum and she thinks that he's consuming
alcohol again
now again all this really does is kind
of confuse us a little bit it asks us
the question is he really crazy is he an
alcoholic is this all in his mind or is
it real and so of course his wife says
that she can't handle this anymore that
she's going to go to a friend Julie's
house which may be maybe a sister or a
friend were not really sure yet and
Robert Reynolds rationalizes again using
his inner monologue that it's safer for
her if she leaves and so he simply says
okay from here his wife seems a little
disheartened that after all they've
apparently been through things that we
haven't seen in this comic because it
picks up in the middle of everything
that he would simply just let her go as
opposed to opening up to her and telling
her what it is that's going on from here
his wife seems to have left and Robert
Reynolds of course begins to recollect
on what's going on that nobody remembers
that he's the century except for him
that he was a hero that he had his ups
and his downs but in the end he always
did the right thing and the question is
what's happened that has caused him to
forget what's happened that's caused
everybody else to forget and so what we
see is I these sort of puts on this
makeshift suit this sort of I guess what
he perceives to be his own suit and
again this asked us the question is
Robert riddles crazy or is this all just
actually happening but at the end of the
comment what we learned is that it is
happening that Robert Reynolds is in
fact the century as Robert Reynolds
begins to fly or at the very least
simply just levitate himself into into
the air now from here over the next
three comics what we will see is that
Robert riddles will approach various
superheroes and what this does is it
gives credence to this idea that this
century was a very old character that
had predated the Fantastic Four that he
had fought alongside Iron Man and
spider-man and the Fantastic Four and
the x-men because what we see is that he
visits each one of these groups or
individuals in turn and tries to get
them to remember who he is and what we
also see
is that while these individuals begin to
slowly recollect who he is while they
begin to slowly remember who it is that
he that he is as a person that for some
reason they can't they just can't break
the barrier they can't remember all the
escapades that this century was involved
in they can't remember fighting
side-by-side they simply just recognized
the name but what we also see over the
course of this comic is that over the
course of these comic books is that
eventually this century stumbles across
his watchtower which is something that
he had simply just remembered something
that he just recollected and that
because he recalled it it was suddenly
there now the question that has to be
asked here is did he simply just I guess
will it into existence or had it always
been there and that questions answered
when he actually approaches the
watchtower when he enters the watchtower
and he finds his AI assistant named
clock now I can't remember off the top
my head exactly what clock stands for
but all it is is really just a sort of I
guess maybe autonomous robot that is his
own personal assistant and carries out
what it is that he needs to have done
and what we see is that some sort of
transmitter was installed and clock and
this transmitter alongside the powers of
the century effectively forced everybody
to forget his existence now why we don't
really know but what we see is that
Robert Reynolds stumbles across some
evidence indicating that perhaps Reed
Richards had a hand in this and that
maybe Reed Richards had simply just
betrayed him from here we see that the
century eventually comes around some
footage where where when he had
supposedly died that Reed Richards gives
a eulogy that effectively tells
everybody that the century was a sham
that Robert Reynolds was a liar that
Robert Reynolds used his ability to
manipulate to steal to get involved in
crime syndicates and that he wasn't this
sort of golden hero that everybody get
painted him out to be that he was a far
more sinister person now as a story
begins to unfold even more what we see
is that eventually Robert Reynolds comes
to this understanding that the void of
course is returning the void is coming
back and that while he does need to
ultimately confront Reed Richards over
this that there are far more important
things to worry about that there are
much bigger pictures here that Reed
Richards and the end the century where
friends at some point in time and so
there's really no reason for him
believe that that Reed Richards would in
effect somehow do him wrong but at the
same time he can't help but believe that
this may very well be the case given the
information that's been provided to him
ultimately what we see is this sort of
series of events come to a head and the
final issue of the century versus the
void which is sort of outside maybe this
five issue limited series but is the
conclusion to this entire event and what
we see here is that the void has arrived
in New York and that the contingent of
superheroes composed of the Incredible
Hulk
and Captain America and all of these
various individuals that had supposedly
fought alongside the century when we
were expected to believe that he was
around in the 1960s that they're all
there to confront the void that they're
all there to effectively try to do what
they can in order to keep the void keep
the void away in addition what we see is
that Doctor Strange appears to read
Richards and Doctor Strange begins to
talk to Reed Richards and say that Reed
Richards needs to remember that he needs
to recall what it was it took place and
what we see or what we get is this sort
of final explanation where we get the
missing pieces to this puzzle of what
happened between the time that the
century existed in Marvel Comics and up
until this current point and what we see
is that during a conflict in New York
City that had taken place before these
five issue limited series and now Marvel
Comics is that the void had attached New
York City and had eradicated about a
million or so people and it caused a
massive amount of devastation and what
the Fantastic Four had learned is that
Robert Robert Reynolds is actually the
void that this century is the other half
of his personality and so the century
and the void are two sides of the same
coin indicating to us that there may
very well be some kind of psychosis or
there may very well be some kind of
schizophrenia going on in the mind of
Robert Reynolds and that Robert Reynolds
at this point doesn't remember this he
doesn't know that he and the void to him
there are two different people what we
see is that with Reed Richards he gives
us again this entire story and what we
learn here is that Robert riddles
himself was the one who decided that the
century needed to be forgotten but the
century needed to go away
because if the century is remembered by
anybody on earth then the void could
exist as long as no one knows who this
century is including Robert Reynolds
himself the void simply just can't be
there because Robert riddles won't know
who the void is and so what we see is
that Robert Reynolds the century Reed
Richards along with various other
individuals travel to the sentries
watchtower and they install this sort of
device that's designed to make everyone
forget about who this century is and we
see this again this sort of circumstance
reinventing itself we see this sort of
sort of circumstance coming around again
when Robert Reynolds remembers all of
this when this all begins to flood in
when he recalls everything that's been
going on and he recalls the full
memories of the fact that he is the void
and these are the steps that he had
previously taken to eliminate the void
from reality and so what we see is that
once again the fantastic Ford Reed
Richards along with Doctor Strange the
century and various other individuals
head back to the watchtower once again
in order to tell clock that they need to
reinitialize this this transmitter in
order to make everybody forget who this
century is but we also see is that the
void tries to stop the century from
doing this that the void tries to stop
the century from engaging in this
activity and this is something I would
like for you guys to be very close
attention to because the question that I
would submit to you is this when Robert
Reynolds first took the Super Soldier
Serum who did he become did he become
the void or did he become the century is
the century the actual the real
personality of Robert Reynolds or is the
void the real personality of Robert
Reynolds and this is a question that
will answer later on and this series but
this is one of the best elements of this
this this series because what it does is
it asks us or it really kind of gives us
a reason to to ask this question of
which one is which which side is which
who is Robert Reynolds really from here
what we see is that the transmitter is
activated and that a wave of energy is
spread throughout the world and that
everybody begins to forget about the
century which includes of course Robert
riddles himself now again what we see
going on here is
Robert Reynolds sort of reverts back to
his regular life where he's simply just
a man living in a house and he's with
his wife what we also see going on is
that because the world doesn't remember
who Robert Reynolds is because they
don't remember who this century is that
all the destruction that had taken place
at the hands of these various
superheroes fighting the void is
attributed to a natural disaster of some
kind to a hurricane or a storm or
something like that at the as the comic
comes to a close or as a series begins
to come to an end what we see is that
Robert Reynolds arrives at the burger
palace of course a place where he and
his wife intend to eat and they of
course order their respective foods when
the the person at the register who has a
scar on his face and is missing an arm
ask Robert Reynolds what it is that he
wants Robert Reynolds has a flashback
where he B calls himself as the century
alongside this young man as a sidekick
eating chili dogs and talking about how
this is humanity's only hope indicating
to us that not all hope is lost that
Robert Reynolds could very well return
as the century which is something that
we will see picked up as we move on to
the centuries reappearance and the
creation of the New Avengers and the
Marvel Universe